you need money okay we'll sell you off
as a medical experiment we can get you
money that way
if i decided tomorrow that i wish
amazon did less pioneering
and more close following i couldn't do
it
in the beginning there will be there
will be a few people who
who who believe in you or in what you're
doing want to be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe
life and learn how billionaires think to
get some success
advice from the top enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be persuasive with elon musk
if you think about a company a company
is is a group of people that are
organized to create a product or service
that's a sort of company is so in order
to
create such a thing you have to convince
others to
join you in in your effort um
and and and so they have to be convinced
that
that that it's a sensible thing that
it's like that there's at least some
some good some reasonable chance of
success uh and if there is success that
the reward will be commensurate with the
effort involved
um and uh
you know so i think that's getting
people to
to believe in what you're doing uh and
in
in you is is important um
so in the beginning there will be
there will be a few people who who who
believe in you
or in what you're doing um and uh
but then over time as you make progress
that the evidence will build
and and more people will believe in what
you're doing
so um i think it's a good idea when
creating a company to
um to create it to have a demonstration
or you know if it's a product to have
like a a good mock-up or
even if software to have good demo wear
or to be able to sketch something so
people can really envision what it's
about
um like that that's a try to get to that
point as soon as possible and then
iterate to make it as as real as
possible as fast as possible
rule number two build a strong company
culture with jeff bezos
my opinion is that i can do some things
that amazon
that would be hard for other people to
do only because of my history with the
company
and my as the company has grown of
course
my job has changed very much and um
it has my main job today is i'm kind of
the
i i i work hard at helping to maintain
the culture
um you know a culture of high standards
of operational excellence
of you know of inventiveness of
willingness to fail uh willingness to
make bold experiments
i'm the i'm i'm i'm you know i'm the guy
i'm the counterbalance to the
institutional know who can say yes
um but i won't you know i'm not going to
be here forever amazon is a really
uh the many of the traits that make
amazon
unusual are now deeply ingrained in the
culture in fact if i wanted to change
them i couldn't if i decided
tomorrow that i wish amazon did less
pioneering
and more close following i couldn't do
it
the culture is um is
you know cultures are self-reinforcing
and that's a good thing
um you know the the the people who come
to the company
we get sometimes people come to the
company and they can't they're
they find amazon very boring because we
don't have enough you know competitive
zeal you know we don't wake up some
annual planning processes and so and
some companies literally start with who
are our three biggest enemies
and then you know here's how we're going
to hold them at bay or defeat them
and we don't have such a list at amazon
it's not how our annual planning process
works and so but if you're on the other
hand if you're the kind of person who
gets up in the morning and says
in the shower time you know what can we
invent for customers and what can we do
differently and
how can we improve that experience and
so on and so on then you know then it's
going to be a playground
is there i still run into work by the
way i took my family on vacation
to france my wife's extended family
there are about 20 of us
and we had an unbelievably good time
great food everything we were there for
a week i got back to seattle and i ran
into the office i'm having so much fun
rule number three outwork everyone with
mark cuban
most people do a lot of talking and most
people don't put in the effort
there's nothing you can't accomplish in
in life
with the right amount of work the
challenge is you know are you willing to
to do the work and
the reality is most people aren't but
that's the opportunity
right it's i mean it's like people you
know at school
most people are lazy right they they
just they barely get through it and
and so that creates opportunity i tell
my kids that
a if they want something they're going
to have to earn it
yeah and b if they don't work hard
enough to earn it i'm going to sell them
off as medical experiments
[Laughter]
that's the line in our house right
i'm going to sell you off this medical
experience
you need money okay we'll sell you off
as a medical experiment we can get you
money that way
i'll go give blood dad i'm seven i don't
care
also if you want to have more self
belief and more self confidence i've
created a special
free program where every day for the
next 254 days i will send you
an unlisted video to help you boost your
self belief and self confidence the link
to join for free
is in the description below but if you
ask me to write a story on what is
potomac electric power worth or
something like that i can write the
story and that's what i'm doing every
day i'm assigning myself a story and
then i go out and
so you get i've always been passionate
some people thought you know
it's it's more ocd than anything else
starting companies like
staring into the abyss and eating glass
rule number four
choose the right heroes with warren
buffett i was very lucky in life
if you tell me who your heroes are i i
will
make a pretty good prediction about how
what you're going to do and i
i i had the right heroes i was very
lucky in life and uh
my heroes never let me down and started
with my dad
and then i had others in business and so
i have had
great teachers some formal teachers some
that were just
informal teachers teachers by instinct
or example
and if i hadn't had those
you know my life i'm sure would have
been very different rule number five
make a choice with oprah winfrey we have
to make the choice
every single day to channel our own
inner jucindas to
exemplify the truth and the respect
and the grace that we actually
wish for the world we need to tell it
as we're doing at this conference we
need to
write it we need to sing it we need to
proclaim it
we need to be it we need to be the truth
we have to be the respect we have to be
the fierceness
the love that we want to see and when we
do that
mark my words a change is
already coming rule number six conquer
self-doubt with jesse itzler now fear
is a really powerful thing but when you
surrender and say i'm not scared
of fear it's unbelievably liberating
now i don't like to be embarrassed but
i'm not scared of it
but it wasn't always like that for me
when i was a senior
in uh college there was a girl that i
liked
i had to have my roommate in college
call her up and ask her to go to the
formal as
me he literally called up said hey this
is jesse
that fast forward 20 years i like this
girl
i'm trying to quarter she's the founder
of spanx
i call the phone i call the her
assistant at spanx
and this is the same time that i'm about
to run a 100 mile race
non-stop in 24 hours for charity
i call up i get to the assistant and i
said uh can you tell
sarah that i would love to wear spanx if
in this 100-mile race if she would give
me a testimonial from my website
i don't want a testimonial i wanted
sarah
obviously the assistant goes hold on one
second
puts me on hold and says sarah there's
some lunatic
on the phone that wants to run a hundred
miles
in spanx she says
i think i might know that lunatic and a
year later
she married the lunatic
but in between that time when my
roommate had a call
to ask this girl for a date so when i
got
sarah i call it like the lamb mentality
and the lion mentality there was a lot
of self-doubt
and self-doubt is probably the biggest
enemy
to creativity and the way you conquer
self-doubt
is by doing things that make you
uncomfortable and rule number seven the
last one before very special bonus clip
is
learn from experience with john paul de
jouria
how did you get through like tactically
to a sale in the encyclopedia world like
people don't want to hear from you so
like how do you overcome that what a
question asked me
the average encyclopedia salesman
lasted three days i was at it for three
and a half years
and the way it worked in those days it
was commission only so the way it worked
is you went for an interview
they told you all you could possibly
make off commission only
and we were in training for three days
it was a presentation that was scripted
we'd have to memorize the whole thing
well when you got in the field you
remember
parts of it you knock on doors you're
not quite sure of yourself a lot of
dirts are close in your face
but what happens after a while you start
getting used to it and you see
what you can say or do that'll make it
better
but when you go back the next day with
your other sales people what you see
what you do what did i say
uh so let's say knock on 100 door skin
into one give
10 presentations to sell one book but
then when you get better and better at
it
through your experiences and losses
along the way it sharpens you up
where all of a sudden i got to a point
where if i gave three presentations i
have no less than
one order commission only but i believe
that i could do that i believe that
colleges were the best set of books
because a high school student could read
it it wasn't like a college manual you
had to read
and i was doing something good for
somebody so you have to believe
that what you're doing is good is going
to benefit somebody and you learn as you
go
okay do i look someone in the eye see a
lot of people don't know these things
look someone in the eye
all too often people say it's hard to
look someone in the eye
because you feel uncomfortable of course
you do they're not on the same
wavelength you're under the same
frequency so what do you do how do you
overcome that
you learn these things along the way you
look them right between the eyes or
their eyebrows looks like you're looking
over the eye
i've been working on a book for a couple
of years with some of these tips and
it's not ready yet maybe next year it'll
be ready but uh
there's all these things and of course
smile smile's the most wonderful thing
god gave us
and you don't smile when you first talk
to somebody you smile before you knock
on their door
and if your day sucks you fake it hi how
you doing so when you smile
everything changes people change now
i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your specific plan of action
for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create
a specific plan of action you have a 91
chance of following through that's what
we do here believe nation we get
motivated but then we do
something about it and when you commit
to other people you increase your
chances
even further of following through so
what was your biggest takeaway from this
video
and then what is your plan of action
around for this week
put it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate
you one of the things when i really sit
and think why
why am i comfortable taking risks what
is it yeah
um where i come from i was really lucky
when i was growing up my dad
used to actually encourage my brother
and me to fail
and so i would come home and sit at the
dinner table and he would say
sarah what did you fail at this week and
if i didn't have something he would
actually be disappointed
and i can vividly remember coming home
and saying dad dad i tried out for this
and i was
horrible and he would high-five me and
what i i didn't realize it's so awesome
i didn't realize it at the time but it
was
he was teaching us that failure is is
not
trying versus the outcome and so with
spanx and everyone saying it was such a
bad idea
initially and you know i feel like i i
feel much freer
to be willing to you know fail in the
traditional sense
because i'm not focused on the out end
result and the more it's like
working a muscle the more you're willing
to risk something and maybe
fail you realize there's always a really
awesome hidden gift in it
it's either you meet someone new that
brings you to a different place in your
life or you learn something new
or and and so i always was really
excited by
what how my life grew by every risk i
took
[Music]
if you want seven more lessons from how
billionaires think check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there at amazon one of
the things we try to do
is have multiple paths to yes you don't
have solutions
for artificial intelligence